en medio de un inestable panorama
político comenzaron los interrogatorios
por el asesinato del presidente haitiano
joven el mois la fiscalía quiere
determinar el rol del personal de
seguridad en el asesinato así como el de
ex senadores opositores
comsa de vetar en todo el radio el
fiscal quiere escucharnos lo más
importante para benoit y la tortura es
la justicia para yo en el móvil porque
también quieren saber el origen de este
crimen es inaceptable que un presidente
sea asesinado en su residencia
el ex senador stevens bengua llegó a
firmar a la prensa local que moix fue
asesinado por su propio cuerpo de
seguridad su hipótesis podría encontrar
respaldo en las conclusiones que
desvelaron este lunes las autoridades
colombianas que colaboran en el caso el
jefe de seguridad del palacio
presidencial de haití de michigan hizo
este año varios viajes a colombia ya
otros países latinoamericanos con
propósitos que se desconocen que el
comisario
ligera jefe de la unidad seguridad jefe
de la unidad de seguridad general del
palacio nacional de haití habría
realizado viajes a ecuador panamá
república dominicana utilizando como
tránsito a colombia las autoridades
estadounidenses también avanzan con la
investigación un funcionario de la
administración de control de drogas de
estados unidos la dea anunció el lunes
que uno de los hombres haitiano
estadounidenses detenidos en haití había
sido informante de la misma agencia
aunque no era un informante activo en el
momento del asesinato según una fuente
policial